oui et non
pendant la première guerre mondiale les
missions de reconnaissance maritime et
de lutte anti sous marine était dévolue
aux hydravions du royal naval air
service
en 1936 ces deux missions furent placés
sous la responsabilité du coastal
commandes récemment créé
bien qu épaulés par des avions terrestre
comme le à bronson ou le locle datsun et
des bombardiers reconverti comme le
libérateur et le b 17 les hydravions du
coastal commandes furent au sommet de
leur carrière durant la seconde guerre
mondiale
en 1945 le short sunderland et le
consolidated catalina étaient devenus
les armes particulièrement efficace
contre les sous marins et les navires de
surface
la guerre avait aussi prouver la
nécessité de disposer d'un service de
secours en mer au sein des forces
aériennes les hydravions avait montré
toute leur efficacité dans ses missions
autant que dans leur fonction première
mais en dépit de leur succès dans ces
trois missions l'intérêt officiel pour
ce type d'avion était sur le déclin
un avion terrestre le havre ou
shackleton fut choisi pour remplacer les
avions américains acquis par le système
prêt bail dans la ras d'après guerre
résultat de l'évolution du bombardier
lincoln il fut le dernier avion à moteur
à pistons à être utilisé en première
ligne par la r f
conçu pour être un appareil de
transition avant qu'un avion
spécifiquement dédié à cette mission ne
soit construit le chacal tonnes entrée
en service en 1951
il fut la colonne vertébrale du coastal
commandes jusqu'à l'arrivée du nimrod 18
ans plus tard
en 1952 un an après l'entrée en service
du shackleton dans la r f de havilland
présenta le premier avion de ligne à
réaction
le com est un
les sous marins les plus modernes était
à la fois plus rapide et plus silencieux
que leurs prédécesseurs de la seconde
guerre mondiale grâce à une autonomie
accrue et une capacité à rester plus
longtemps en plongée il était devenu
très difficile à détecter
l'union soviétique développer une
importante flotte comprenant des sous
marins à propulsion nucléaire et la
menace qu'ils constituaient nécessitait
des avions plus puissant et plus moderne
que le chacal tonnes
et
en dépit des accidents des comet en 1953
et 1954
en 1960 la tension des officiels se
porta sur cet avion de ligne lorsqu'il
entra en service en 1956 le comedd deux
équipes à le premier escadron de
transport disposant d'avions à réaction
les comètes civile avait prouvé par l'
usage intensif qu'on faisait les
compagnies aériennes que le réacteur
rolls royce even pouvait les emmener
facilement vers n'importe quel aérodrome
de la planète
les exigences de la rff pour le
remplacement du shackleton portait sur
la capacité à transiter vers un point
éloigné dans le plus court délai
possible
une fois dans la zone cible l'avion
devait être capable de voler
suffisamment lentement pour effectuer
une recherche efficace et dans le même
temps être assez manoeuvrant pour
attaquer à basse altitude
le chacal tonnes s'étaient avérées très
fatigant pour ses équipages lors des
longs vols de transit
l'aménagement du nouvel appareil devait
donc être conçu pour économiser les
forces de son équipage
avec l'arrivée du comedd 4 c'est en 1962
l'avion voyait sa vitesse et sa masse
augmenté
ils pouvaient emporter 94 passagers plus
du double du comedd 2 et avait une
vitesse maximum de 800 km pour le
remplacement du shackleton le comedd 4
était un choix évident
non
en juin 1964 le ministère de l'air
publié à la note 380 qui définissait les
grandes lignes pour l'avion à venir et
l'année suivante le gouvernement annonce
a finalement que cette fiche programme
serait rempli par une version maritime
du comedd 4
l'avion de ligne avait une charge utile
supérieure à 10 tonnes
mais pour laisser de la place au très
volumineuse équipements spécialisés et
armement demandé par la r f
la cellule du comet de mettre d'être
élargie
ce concept donna naissance à un nouvel
avion doté d'une section non pressurisée
c'est à dire la soute armement ajouté
sous le fuselage pressurisée du comet
les moteurs standards du comet les rolls
royce even furent remplacées par des
réacteurs militaire plus puissants les
rolls royce pays avec une poussée
unitaire de 5 mille deux cents kilos le
spel disposait d'une puissance
supérieure de 1800 kg
le travail commence à sur le prototype
en 1965
il était conçu à partir d'une cellule
neuf mais non terminés d'un comète
il fut construit acheteurs aient reçu le
numéro de série rs x et 148
en 1967 le nouvel appareil reçu
officiellement le nom de nimrod du nom
d'un valeureux chasseurs du livre de la
genèse
le 23 mai le prototype décollera pour la
première fois entre les mains du pilote
d'essais de hawker siddeley john
cunningham
deux mois plus tard il fut suivi par le
vol inaugural d'un second prototype
le xv et 147 le nimrod conservait la
même envergure que le comet soit 34 m
un radôme ajouté à la queue augmenté
notablement la longueur totale de
l'avion
les hublots supplémentaires furent
ajoutés au cockpit pour améliorer la
visibilité de l'équipage lors de ces
manoeuvres
grâce à des réservoirs de carburant
additionnels et des moteurs plus
puissants
le nimrod avait le double d'autonomie
que ses équivalents civile en dépit de
sa masse maximale de 85 tonnes un
réservoir de carburant fut ajoutée sur
le board attaques de chats qu'elle est
un phare de recherche de 70 millions de
kandla fut installé dans celui de
tribord
les deux prototypes furent utilisés pour
le développement du concept
le xv et 147 fut employé comme banc
d'essai volant pour les équipements
tandis que le xv et 148 fut utilisé pour
les essais le travail de développement
sur la cellule et les réacteurs
le premier nimrod de production toutes
équipées nimrod mr1 fit son premier vol
le 28 juin 1968 avec une vitesse
maximale de 900 km heure et une vitesse
de croisière de 580 km heure son
autonomie maximale est de 9 mille six
cents kilomètres
il peut tenir douze heures en l'air ces
chiffres signifient que l'avion est
capable de se rendre à 1600 km de sa
base relativement grande vitesse
arrivé sur sa cible ou dans la zone de
recherche il peut patrouiller plus de
six heures
trois autres et meyrin suivirent la
première machine et à l'automne 1969
le xv et 230 devint le premier des 40
mr1 commande est entré en service au
sein de la r f
il fut le premier quadriréacteur de
toutes les forces aériennes du monde à
être utilisé comme avion de patrouille
maritime
le xv et 230 fut livrée aux squadron de
transformation opérationnelle 236 basée
à st morgan au moment même où le
cocktail commande était dissous pour
être remplacé par le nouveau groupe
maritime 18 du strike command
en 1972 les mr1 restants avaient tous
été livrés ensemble il équipait 5
squadron du strike command basé au
royaume uni et deux autres basé à malte
et en sicile
au moment de son entrée en service
l'équipement que le nimrod emportait
était déjà bien loin des bricolages
employés pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale l'arrivée du détecteur
d'anomalie magnétique donnait aux nimrod
la capacité importante de faire la
distinction entre un sous marin et
d'autres contacts trompeurs comme les
bancs de poissons
les systèmes de détection sous marin
avait évolué depuis les as dit de
l'époque de la guerre pour devenir des
outils d coûte les fameuses bouées
acoustiques
en plus de bombes conventionnelles une
grande variété d'armement comprenant les
plus modernes torpilles et des charges
de profondeur nucléaire les bombes à
fragmentation et des missiles terre-mer
pouvait être embarqué dans la soute
ventrale
le mr1 et est équipé du radar as v 21
originalement utilisé sur les dernières
versions du chat kelton
avec une portée de 270 km le sv 21 et
est un radar efficace mais d'autres
systèmes plus avancé encore était à
l'horizon
il avait été décidé presque au départ du
projet que tous les nids mode
disposerait du nouveau et hautement
sophistiqué système e est mis surtout
auteur
cette décision en plus de nouveaux
développements dans d'autres domaines de
l'électronique embarquée conduisit un
chantier de modernisation de la version
est meyrin
comme des systèmes de plus en plus
complexes et avancer devenait
opérationnel la version à meyrin allait
être convertie au bout d'un certain
temps en un nouveau standard sous le nom
de nimrod mr2
commencé en 1975 le programme de
conversion devait durer les dix années
suivantes
l'essentiel des changements concerner
l'installation de nouveaux équipements
et les modifications de l'organisation
des différentes antennes de pod chacun
disposant de radôme avant et arrière fut
remonté en bout d'aile pour abriter les
équipements du système de mesure de
soutien électronique l'oral l'apparence
extérieure de l'avion en fut grandement
modifié
en plus de ces deux missions de
reconnaissance maritime et de lutte anti
sous marine un troisième est tout aussi
vital rôle était prévu pour le nimrod
celui d'avions d'alert aéroportée avancé
à eux w qui devaient être employées pour
contrer la menace d'avion au style ou de
missiles entrant dans l'espace aérien
britannique à basse altitude suivant une
décision du gouvernement de 1969 de
retirer du service les porte avions de
la marine
le système pas eu w devait dans l'avenir
également procuré une protection aux
navires de la flotte depuis des bases
terrestres
ces questions
annoncé en 1977 le nimrod à eux w3
devait remplacer les vieux shackleton hw
ii qui avait dû tenir ce rôle de façon
temporaire au début de la décennie
utilisant le fuselage est maire le
premier appareil de développement du a
eu double v 3 d cola en juillet 1981 il
était doté de deux radôme volumineux
chacun abritant une antenne radar
marconi de 180° monté à l'avant et à
l'arrière du fuselage
ces deux radars permettait une
couverture à longue distance sur 360
degrés
une fois un intrus localiser un système
de traitement de données sophistiqués le
suivait tandis que des chasseurs étaient
envoyés pour l'intercepter ou le
détruire
l'équipement radio était très complet et
le à eux w3 pouvez communiquer avec
n'importe quel navire stations
terrestres ou sous marins on espérait
pouvoir produire un total de onze avions
mais le projet fut constamment
confrontés à des retards à répétition
les problèmes avec l'installation des
équipements électroniques due à la
taille de la cellule d'umr conduisirent
à une spirale d'augmentation des
au milieu des années 80 après que les
dépenses et dépasser le milliard de
livres sterling le gouvernement commence
à envisager sérieusement d'autres
options
à
libault in de trois awacs était en
service avec l' us air force depuis 1981
et 18 d'entre eux avaient rejoint la
flotte de l'otan
une énorme antenne radar monter au
sommet du fuselage de n'être à la wax
une portée effective supérieure à 400 km
après bien des débats le gouvernement se
prononcera en faveur de l'avion
américain
en décembre 1986 il annonce à
l'annulation du projet du nimrod w
quatre ans auparavant la guerre des
malouines avait entraîné de très rapides
modifications sur les nimrod mrd pylônes
furent installés permettant à l'avion
d'emporter des missiles air air
sidewinder pour son auto-défense
afin de couvrir les navires et les
avions convoyés vers l'atlantique sud
et pour donner assez d'autonomie aux
patrouilles à longue distance autour des
îles falkland les nimrod avait besoin
d'un système de ravitaillement en vol
ce fut pour les ingénieurs une véritable
course contre la montre les perche de
ravitaillement en vol fut rajouté au
dessus du cockpit et tout le système de
canalisation fut créée et installée en
moins de trois semaines ses avions ainsi
équipés re sur la désignation de nimrod
mr2 p il pouvait rester en vol pendant
près de 20 heures après la guerre le
programme de conversion des mers 2
continue à tel qu'il avait été
originellement prévu les fut effectuée
en moins de deux ans
à l'automne 1984 le dernier est meyrin
décollé de sa base pour rejoindre l'
usine de woodford
il
pour faire voler cet avion et se servir
de l'équipement complexe qui l'emportait
l'équipage d'un nimrod et
inhabituellement importants
un stand l'équipage standard d'un nimrod
et de 13 hommes dont cinq officiers
les huit autres sont des sous-officiers
les deux pilotes sont généralement au
grade de flight lieutenant ou de flying
fils heures un mécanicien navigant
sous-officier d'expérience mais chaque
unité à un chef mécanicien de bord qui
est officier deux officiers navigateur
tu es un officiel d'electronic nous
avons ce que nous appelons les équipes
mouillé et sèche
l'équipe mouillée est en charge du côté
acoustique de l'appareil et tandis que
l'équipe sèche s'occupe du radar de la
radio des mesures de soutien
électronique et du mad détection
d'anomalies magnétique
ce sont des sous-officiers d'expérience
il y en a normalement trois dans
l'équipe mouillé et quatre dans l'équipe
sèche
la mission du nimrod et la surveillance
maritime et la lutte anti sous marine
un avion est en alerte en une heure pour
les besoins de recherche et sauvetage
365 jours par an lors d'une journée
normale l'équipage arrive environ deux
heures et demie avant le décollage pour
préparer la mission généralement une
heure et demie avant l'heure prévue pour
le vol l'équipage se rassemblent pour un
briefing et discute de son bon
déroulement
ensuite il se rend à l'avion une heure
avant et mêlée réacteurs en route 20
minutes avant le décollage
et puis ils partent ils partent six
heures pour une mission d'entraînement
pour l'équipage 3 à 4 heures pour un vol
d'entraînement pour les pilotes et 8
heures pour une mission opérationnelle
après l'atterrissage il faut stopper
l'avion faire un débriefing avec les
équipes au sol sur les éventuels
problèmes rencontrés avec l'avion
retourner aux opérations pour un
débriefing d'équipage avant de rentrer à
la maison
une longue journée
monde
m
le nimrod et manoeuvré par un pilote et
un co pilote le mécanicien navigant est
assis derrière eux sur le côté droit du
fuselage
derrière le cockpit se trouve la console
de navigation et les deux navigateurs
le premier est en charge d'amener
l'avion au bon endroit au bon moment et
de gérer les différents aspects d'une
navigation ordinaire à côté de lui ça
ciel le navigateur tactique
lorsque l'avion arrive sur zone il prend
à son compte la navigation les en
fonction de la mission dirige l'avion
les informations sont données par le
pilote automatique smith les systèmes de
navigation et le radar ainsi que les
données des systèmes électroniques de
combat et d'armement qui alimentent le
système tactique il est au coeur du
nimrod le résultat est affichée sur un
écran circulaire de 24 pouces en
montrant la position de l'avion et les
positions relatives des sous marins des
navires de surface et des bouées
acoustiques le navigateur tactique
dispose d'une vision complète de la
situation générale avec ces informations
continuellement mises à jour il peut
utiliser le pilote automatique pour
diriger le nimrod vers n'importe quel
point intéressant derrière les
navigateurs les équipements
électroniques restants sont surveillés
par un officier à eux au l électronique
officer et par un groupe d'opérateurs
acoustique un opérateur radar et un
autre en charge du malade et des mesures
de soutien électronique
le sm là-haut supervise une équipe de
trois acousticien assis face à une large
console installé sur le côté tribord de
l'avion
le nimrod emporte une importante
cargaison de bouées acoustiques
constituée de modèles passif et actif
bien qu'elle soit tout conçu pour
détecter les bruits sous la mer elle
utilise différents principes les boues
et passives telles le modèle djebel
écoute les sons via un hydrophone sur le
principe d'un micro sous marin des boues
et active comme les routeurs opèrent
selon le principe de la sdig de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
en émettant leurs propres signal sonore
quand ce sont touche un sous marin le
signal est renvoyé si bien que les
bouées perçoivent leur propre échos
les signaux reçus à la fois par les
bouées active et passive peuvent être
analysées par les opérateurs acoustique
du nimrod avec l'aide d'un système
marcognac us 901
pour une chasse aux sous marins
classiques un hymne rock commencerait
par larguer des bouées passive autour de
la position supposée de la cible elles
peuvent être largué une à une par un
danseur simple ou bien en quantité en
utilisant un ou deux des lanceurs à six
tubes installé à l'arrière du fuselage
complètement silencieuse les weppes
passives sont capables d'écouter tout en
étant totalement indétectable par les
appareils du sous marin
quand un contact positif est établi le
nimrod valence et les goûts et active
selon un quadrillage précis pour
déterminer la position et la direction
de la cible
aussitôt qu'elle commence à transmettre
le son émis par les bouées active peut
être facilement perçue par la cible
mais au moment où le sous-marin détecte
la présence de son chasseur il est
possible qu'il soit déjà trop tard pour
fuir
dans l'avion le à thuès 901 traite
toutes les informations reçues des
bouées acoustiques et affiche les
résultats pour les opérateurs
chacun d'eux est entraîné à l'art
d'interpréter l'affichage de la q s mais
si nécessaire de transmettre les infos
au navigateur tactique
ce dernier est capable de gérer la
situation planifier la tacc du nimrod et
coordonner le système d'armes
à l'opposé des opérateurs acoustique se
trouvent les opérateurs radar le radar
est mis sur twitter est un système erp
surface capable de détecter les plus
gros navires a une portée supérieure à
200 km
il peut permettre d'identifier ces
navires en dessinant leur silhouette sur
l'écran et avec sa haute résolution peut
détecter un très discret périscope à
longue distance même par mer agitée tout
comme le modèle e w3 les nimrod mrd
dispose d'une pléthore d'équipements de
radiocommunication afin de pourvoir à
toute éventualité
ces équipements de communication
comporte un ff identificateur ami/ennemi
un système de brouillage et un récepteur
pour capter les signaux de détresse des
balises de secours
tous ces équipements sont sous la
responsabilité de l'opérateur radio de
la console située à bâbord
le détecteur d'anomalie magnétique made
est un autre outil de détection passive
de sous marins
tout objet métallique important cause
des perturbations du champ magnétique
terrestre
puisque la coque d'un sous-marin est
constituée de métal ferreux il en
résulte une modification magnétique
local qui peut être perçue par le
système made
une fois que la cible a été localisé au
radar et la position précise et grâce
aux bouées acoustiques le mad apporte
une preuve définitive de la présence
d'un sous marin
pour éviter les perturbations du système
entraînée par la masse métallique que
constitue l'avion le système de
détection made est installé dans la
longue perche fixer tout à l'arrière de
la queue de l'avion
même si le nimrod peut-on porter une
grande variété d'armes y compris des
charges nucléaires de profondeur son
armement principal est constitué de
torpilles à guidage acoustique la
torpille 46 est doté d'un système qui
lui permet de chercher et d'attaquer un
sous marin en filant à très haute
vitesse en eaux profondes
la torpille stingray dispose de son
propre ordinateur pour son système de
guidage et peut être utilisé contre le
sous marin naviguant dans les eaux font
comme dans les profondeurs pour attaquer
les bâtiments de surface le nimrod peut
utiliser ces bombes conventionnelles ou
bien le missiles harpoon antinavires
il peut en emporter 2 sous les pylônes
d'elle à la place des missiles air air
sidewinder des lances leurs épaules les
systèmes de défense de l'avion
la photo prend une part importante dans
les missions de reconnaissance d'une
émeraude
plusieurs appareils sont emportés qu'ils
soient fixes ou manipulable
deux sont montés en permanence et
prennent des photos à travers le
fuselage à l'arrière de l'avion
les fenêtres bulle sur les côtés du
fuselage permettent l'emploi d'appareils
photos sans affecter le système de
pressurisation de l'appareil
en reliant les caméras fixes au système
de navigation la position exacte d'un
navire d'un sous marin ou de n'importe
quel autre bateau peut être affiché sur
le cliché
dans le cas d'une intrusion non
autorisée d'un navire de guerre bien
d'un conflit à propos des zones de pêche
les photographies peuvent constituer des
preuves d'infractions
les patrouilles de surveillance de la
pêche sont menées par les nimrod
quotidiennement toute l'année financé
par le ministère de l'agriculture des
pêches et de l'alimentation
ces vols sont généralement appelés
patrouille de tapisserie les preuves
photographiques ramené de chaque vol
sont analysés par les experts du
ministère et si nécessaire des actions
légales peuvent être intentée par les
cours de justice internationale
européenne
la mission principale du nimrod et donc
la surveillance maritime et la lutte
anti sous marine dans ses missions de
recherche et sauvetage à nimrod est en
alerte 365 jours par an et peut être
appelée à l'aide pour de multiples
raisons
ça peut être pour un avion de ligne qui
aurait perdu un réacteur le nimrod
décollerait pour l'escorter jusqu'à
terre assurant sa sécurité vers shannon
en irlande du sud
ce peut être tout aussi bien pour une
explosion sur une plateforme pétrolière
comme c'est arrivé dans le passé pour
rechercher des survivants et coordonner
les secours
le nimrod ne pourrait évidemment pas
s'arrêter pour récupérer quelqu'un son
rôle et de larguer des radeaux de survie
mais surtout de coordonner les secours
en guidant les hélicoptères et en
surveillant leurs positions idées les
navires de surface qu'ils soient civils
ou militaires et contrôler l'ensemble
des moyens impliqués dans la recherche
le matériel emporté pour une mission de
sauvetage comprend des fusées
éclairantes
des radeaux de survie de l'équipement
médical et des balises fumigènes
en raison des conditions météo très
difficiles dans lesquelles le nimrod
peut être amené à voler chaque avion
subi un programme spécial de nettoyage
et d'inspection méticuleuse les embruns
que l'avion a traversé lors de ces vols
à basse altitude peuvent s'accumuler
dans les endroits les plus inattendus
si l'avion vole régulièrement au dessus
de l'eau l'atmosphère salines peut
accélérer les phénomènes de corrosion
si cette corrosion n'est pas surveillée
cela peut entraîner de sérieux dégâts
sur la cellule de l'avion est
inévitablement accélérer son
vieillissement
pour contrer ce problème les nimrod
dispose d'installations de nettoyage
spécifiques qui permettent de laver
l'avion après chaque vol
la maintenance quotidienne comprend d
inspection minutieuse y compris internes
pour éviter tout dégât causé par la
condensation d'eau salée même à
l'intérieur de l'avion à l'occasion des
révisions général tout l'avion est
nettoyée pour enlever toute trace de
corrosion avant que l'avion ne soit
repeint
la grande visite est un entretien majeur
programmé à 2400 heures de vol soit à
peu près quatre ans et demi
nous reconstruisons pratiquement toute
la cellule de l'avion ce qui comprend
l'enlèvement des pièces endommagées
réparation ou le remplacement et la
réinstallation et cet avion est dans le
hangar depuis cent quinze jours
ouvrables il va y passer six mois
je travaille à la cu nimrod de la base
de kinloss je fais partie d instructeur
au sol mon boulot est de donner des
cours au sol aux stagiaires et
occasionnellement des volets sur l'avion
en tant que copilote
on prend cette place mais quelquefois
nous jouons au commandant de bord
aujourd'hui j'ai sur le rôle de copilote
le nimrod aujourd'hui gain de ses
missions primaire de temps de guerre
c'est à dire s'occuper des sous marins
et des navires de surface et ses
missions de temps de paix comme la
recherche et le sauvetage
nous avons des nimrod qui interviennent
au sein des opérations internationales
comme celles menées en ex yougoslavie
après plus d'un quart de siècle et des
milliers d'heures de vol effectués pour
toutes sortes de missions un seul nimrod
a été perdu
en dépit des controverses autour de
l'échec de la version à eux w3 les
nimrod de reconnaissance maritime
continuent leur importante mission
ils ont joué un rôle vital à la fois
pour la défense de la grande bretagne
mais aussi pour la protection de ses
intérêts économiques
au cours des missions cruciales de
recherche et sauvetage ils ont porté
secours à de nombreuses personnes
ils seront en service ou le standard
actuel jusqu'en 2010 et dans l'avenir
sous de nouvelles configurations